ruben was able to come to comprehensive
and he was found to be a good match
for a phase two clinical trial
by two drugs developed by macrogenics
enoblatuzumab
and retifen lamat two different
medicines made to fight cancer but in a
different way
these are immunotherapy drugs that's
huge because
a comprehensive they're able to build
the portfolio of
or build your menu so if you have cancer
and the medication choices don't look so
good you want to look at a different
menu
and so these clinical trials that we
have are
giving you another chance and you don't
have to travel very far to get
these new medications and you don't have
to wait in line
meaning that usually a new medication
might go to a big
famous university which is that's
usually the case so every time
something like this happens in the
valley in in southern nevada
uh companies and universities will take
note and say hey
we can trust these guys bring to send
them the medication so that the patients
don't have to travel and so it
builds our our ability to treat the
patients it gives us a bet a better menu
for our patients and it is huge that
that's that's exciting for me to be able
to work with
the team here at comprehensive the
there's a huge resources of staff
clinical uh coordinators uh
director there's a nurse is everyone and
it requires a
large amount of people to help them
bring these protocols to the city